Good morning, John. First things first, Project
for Awesome is coming and it's coming fast!
Project for Awesome will be a little bit different
this year and it will take place almost exclusively
on Youtube.com. So if you want to participate
at all, even if you're just tuning in for
a little bit, you need to go right now to
Youtube.com/p4a and subscribe. Right now.
It is extremely important to the success of
the Project for Awesome that you do that.
Once again, right now. However many views
this video gets, that is how many people I
expect to be subscribed to Youtube.com/p4a!
People, this is for charity!
Now, if you are going to make a video you
also need to go subscribe to Youtube.com/p4a,
but you should also go to the links in my
pants to get the thumbnail! Now, only partners
can change their thumbnail. If you're not
a partner you can't change your thumbnail.
That's fine - you can still participate in
the project - but you should put "Project
for Awesome" or "P4A" in the title of your
video, and put both of those things in the
tags, so that we can find your Project for
Awesome video! You must then upload those
videos at noon on December 17th and then throughout
the 17th and 18th, the Project for Awesome
crew, including John and I, will be featuring
those videos all over the place - on Projectforawesome.com,
on our mailing list, on the front page of
Youtube, and at Youtube.com/p4a.
Now, on Wednesday I was in Washington, D.C.,
and when we go places, we do Thoughts from
Places.
Good morning John, I woke up this morning
at 6 a.m., and then at 6:30, and then again
at 7:30 because apparently (and I guess somewhat
unsurprisingly) Washington, D.C. must have
more trash than any other city on the planet!
But then the garbage trucks stopped coming
and I woke up blissfully at around 10 a.m.,
dramatically entered my fancy-though-somewhat-tiny
hotel room, turned off Simplynoise.com, which
helped me sleep but failed to drown out the
garbage trucks, and then I took a shower from
a shower head that looked remarkably like
the planetary defense system that the crew
of the starship Enterprise had to battle in
the second season of Star Trek TNG. It totally
freaked me out - I was afraid it was going
to put me in a stasis field - and then I noticed
this mirror. And then I noticed this mirror.
And I notice that there's a hinge on one of
them. And I was trying to figure out why this
mirror had a hinge and I realized it's so
you can do this. They pretty much thought
of everything here at this hotel. And then
I dramatically left my hotel because apparently
my hotel has a thing for curtains, and then
I was released onto the streets of Washington,
D.C. I enjoyed my walk, seeing many monuments
of monumental people. This here is Horis Trinkleton,
the famous cabbage fancier, and here we have
Inglebert Humart, who triumphed at the battle
of Upper Little Bigton, and then I wandered
past the giant temple to Pescandruscus, the
Zoroastrian god of penetration, and finally
we have the monument of Anjou Teleteleteleton,
the inventor of both velcro and the pencil
sharpener. And then by random chance I ran
into Quizzuckle Couleasy Flip, the squirrel
ambassador to the United States. We had a
brief conversation in which he apologized
for the crimes of Scuzzy Kazoozle, and informed
me that since the passage of the Squirrel
Friendliness and Cleanliness Act of 1982,
there has been a dramatic decrease in squirrel-related
fatalities.
So a little-known fact: the squirrels will
only approach humans for two things: food
and to be on Youtube.
Ok, seriously, though, Washington, D.C. really
is an amazing place. It's a place where you
feel the power of our nation's past much more
viscerally. I was in D.C. for a little event
thingy that Youtube was throwing for policy
and politics people. I was on a panel about
using Youtube for good in which I talked all
about the Project for Awesome, of course.
It was fun, but way too short, and I wish
I had taken some video of the amazing Indian
food I got.
John, I'll see you on Monday.
Don't forget to go to Youtube.com/p4a and
subscribe! You can do that right now! That's
the only thing I'm devoting this end screen
to! P4A Youtube.com/p4a go subscribe right
now! You can also subscribe to get email updates.
That is probably a good idea as well. You
will not regret this decision.